[Music]  150 feet underground  in 30 million year old caves  an unforgettable sight glitters in the  dark  the waitomo glowworm caves in new  zealand are home to about 30 000 endemic  arachnocampa luminosa glowworms  [Music]  they spend their days spinning silk  nests from the ceilings  and then lowering threads to fish for  prey much like a spider  the luminescent bead-like strings are  spellbinding  the glowworms use light to attract prey  and burn off waste  the glow is created by a combination of  chemicals given off by the glowworm and  the oxygen in the  air the caves are ideal for the worms as  they need a dark damp location where  their light can be seen  the way tomo caves they call home are  named after the maori words wei which  means water and tomo which means hole or  shaft  [Music]  and although they live deep underground  the journey to see them is never one to  disappoint  [Music]  you